right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting welcome to omix logic and today
we have the open interactive session for
the various call the Mr programs that we
have on genomics and metagenomics and
during the session we will introduce you
to the Omens logical to guide you on how
to navigate it walk you through our
meticulously designed training
curriculums for each program the various
training levels as well as the
associated resources
so before we begin with today's session
for those of you who are joining with us
for the very first time let me also take
a brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are us-based
by informatics company who is working
with multiple academic and Commercial
moderators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics for ax7
and so far the training program have
been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and our training
coordinators are regularly updating and
customizing the curriculum to suit the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
now in order to create a clear path of
skill development we employ the glooms
taxonomy levels of learning it begins
with students recalling and memorizing
facts progresses to understanding the
concepts and applying their knowledge
then moves on to analyzing data and
evaluating methods ultimately students
reach the highest level of learning
where they can design and create their
own original work
and now this is achieved through a
combination of online courses training
modules data analysis tools curated data
sets and interactive mental sessions to
provide theoretical and practical
learning in bi-informatics
now to further enrich the training
curriculum we also provide real case
studies that demonstrate the practical
application of bioinformatic methods and
omics data in fields such as medicine
biotechnology Agriculture and even
astrobiology
and by using publicly available data
sets these projects allow students to
explore and comprehend various research
questions and Analysis
and the omics logic loan portal gives
students options for analyzing a given
data set which is code independent path
or code independent part now if you are
someone who is interested in opting the
non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinismatic processing and
Analysis of data
so this platform includes example
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run
various bioinformatic Pipelines and
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections on this
multi-omix platform we'll be covering
about the by info platform in a short
while
and now here are some of the student
Keys examples that I want to share with
you briefly
so for the very uh one example that I
want to take is our student Ruth we
Watcher she was one of our students who
worked on assessing the underlying
reason for gray matter lesions in
multiple sclerodic patients and she went
on to publish her project in
immunogenetics which is an Open Access
Journal that focuses on the genetic
research areas of autoimmune disorders
such as multiple sclerosis rheumatoid
arthritis and so
and further you also have the
opportunity to participate in
post-presentation competitions and win
exciting cash prizes and twice a year we
conduct the Omens research Symposium
which is an international research event
that brings together experts from all
around the world
and the student projects are not just
limited to University students for
instance Andre muadanu he was a high
school student when he joined one of our
training program and he presented his
Neuroscience project at the regenerone
international science and engineering
fair for which he won the potamkin prize
now this program can also be integrated
as a part of the existing University
curriculum for instance our python
course was part of the systems medicine
graduate program at Georgetown
University
and these projects can also be showcased
for various other purposes so here are
some of the instances of how our former
students have showcased their projects
so for example dealer at Icon who got
accepted to erasmundus imbrce program in
Marine Biology then we had dhruv mehra
who is a Precision medicine graduate
student at Manchester and anushati who
got accepted to the PHD program in
metagenomic at University of Sweden
now faculties and researchers have also
collaborated to our programs to publish
their research work and one of our
collaboration has been with a team of
researchers at nobuchi Memorial
Institute for medical research at the
University of Kana to carry out
computational based study to understand
variants associated with sulfadoxin
resistance in plasmodium calcium
now let's say you are someone with a
passion for Science and business it is
also possible to pursue an
entrepreneurship and business Innovation
track like a team of industrial
researchers from a biotechnology company
in Nigeria
so they work on developing a microbiota
test kit to improve the fertility of
women in Nigeria and improve their
chances of carrying their babies to turn
now these entrepreneurship track are not
just supposed to be pursued by
researchers but by students as well for
instance a group of undergraduate and
postgraduate students worked on
developing an early detection kit for
Alzheimer's disease
so now you can take a look at all of
these student projects and researchers
project at our omex scholarship plan
portal so to view to view these let us
head to the omen storage diploma portal
and for those of you who are joining
with us for the very first time let me
share the link in the chat box
so that uh
you can create an account those
participants who are interested to take
a look at what are the various courses
what other various training programs we
have and what are the various student
projects that have been completed so far
you can take a look at all of these
collections on our website
so um let me just give you a brief demo
on how you can sign up so so those of
you who are starting for the very first
time when you head to the link you will
see a create an account option like so
click on that and there it will ask you
to enter your name email ID password and
click on next and it will ask you to
enter a few more details once that is
done you will be able to log into your
account or if you already have a
existing social media account such as
Google or Facebook or Apple account or
GitHub or Twitter you can also log in
just by clicking on that
now if you are someone who already has
an account on the total then all you can
do is enter your existing email ID and
password and directly sign in so I'll
just pause for a couple of seconds for
those participants who are creating an
account and want to log in they can do
that
and along the way if you are facing any
technical issues while signing up please
feel free to put that in the chat as
well and our technical team will be able
to look into that so I'll just pause for
a couple of seconds and monitor for your
response
for those of you who already have an
account on them please put it done in
the chat box so that I get an idea and
for those who for those of you who are
creating an account and once done put a
yes in the chat box so that I love that
as well
[Music]
all right so I can see that a lot of the
participants have created an account
perfect
Arena says done josra says done Maria
says done
[Music]
Landry says done
all right maybe you who just joined we
are just signing up on the ominous
portal where I can take the participants
and showcase the various poses and
training programs that we have let me
quickly share the link in the chat box
so that uh
you can start with it
right so without further delay I'm just
going to sign in with my existing
account
all right so once you sign in the very
first interface that you are seeing is
the courses page where you will be able
to see a list of collection of courses
that we have on the boardroom so if you
scroll down below you will see a search
bar that says looking for a specific
course and here if you enter a key area
of research interest or let's say a
specific office field that you want to
specialize in then you can enter the
keyword and it will show you the various
courses and example projects that you
that makes use of it so just as an
example I'm just going to enter the
keyword genomics which is associated
with
doing session so as you can see it shows
up the relevant course which is on
genomics as well as a wide variety of
example projects ranging from infectious
diseases to uh oncology and so on so you
can explore this at your own pace and
take a look at the various courses and
example projects that we have on the
portal now once you sign in you also
have to make sure that your profile is
updated so how do you do that you can
head over to the blue bar on the top
that says welcome back with your email
ID click on that and that will directly
take you to your account settings and
here if you click on the profile button
you will be able to
um edit all the account details that you
want to get updated on your profile
which includes your profile image make
sure that your name is in Proctor
spelling and proper capitalization and
you could also link your social media
handles as well as you can see in my
case I've linked my LinkedIn account and
my work ID and I have a brief bio about
yourself as well so that we know who you
are what is your background what are
your research interests and my keys I've
linked I've mentioned my educational
background can be
so once that is done click on update and
that will be getting updated so that was
all about uh that I just wanted to uh
discuss with you so now to uh get
started with the uh fall semester
programs session I will pass on the
stage to my colleague sonalikali